[Music]
all right wrapping up this Thursday
addition to PFC live after the program
we will be talking to Sean McVeigh and
les Snead the general manager and head
coach of the Rams Chargers head coach
Anthony Lin John Lynch of the 49ers Bret
beets the guy who found Patra homes and
also Pete Carroll head coach the Seattle
Seahawks sneaky dark horse candidate for
coach of the year after what he did in
Seattle this year a lot of people wrote
that list a lot of good conversations
and not 13
yesterday it was 30 I had nothing left
by the time we were done it was 14 for
you could you talk to Kyle Shanahan yeah
it was it was the the car wash that I
was sick of talking to anybody by the
end of yesterday hey before we talk
caller Marino's Paul what's your one
lingering enduring memory of your time
at the Scouting Combine 25 years ago I
remember being at the start of the
40-yard dash and it was at the old RCA
Dome and looking around and the only
guys I saw right behind me Bill Parcells
Jimmie Johnson and Al Davis all of a
sudden I was so I was just unbelievably
nervous i adjure E Jones and Bill
Parcells yeah I was right there with you
but go ahead and that's the reason I ran
a 502 instead of him wonder like it was
like mid 20s it's the same score the
John Elway got I know that twenty five
or six or something got like a 35 now no
I think a 27 I want to say I can't name
the team make sure your score gets
better
no well I told you I got lucky on the
illegal test and I just happen to know a
few more of the vocab words like Slumdog
memory that's what it came down to I was
like oh I know and when I got here at
the combine for the Wonderlic I got to
the vocab section and I was like Dan I
don't know these ones and you know me in
the English language we're not always uh
Sympatico so that word which was pretty
impressed I know I can pull him out of
my butt every day right so here's the
thing Tyler Murray is is not going to
throw at the Scouting Combine he told
Scouts and personnel people of several
teams he doesn't plan to throw that's
according to Ian Rapoport of NFL media
they cautioned that Murray is a
competitor who could throw after seeing
everyone else do it but as of last night
Murray's
is to not do too much I hate this old
idea a competitor I don't like it's not
a competition it's an evaluation the
thing that bugs me about this though he
issued this statement a couple of weeks
ago that he's all in with football and
he said in there I eagerly await the
opportunity to show the decision-makers
that I am the franchise quarterback in
the draft this is your opportunity so I
again I if guys don't want to throw
that's fine but you can't put a
statement like that out there and not
throw absolutely I don't think it's fine
for quarterbacks not to throw this is
the one chance the only time and Calum
early may have half the league half the
NFL general managers as pro day this is
the only time he's gonna have all 32
GM's and head coaches there no pass rush
just drop straight back and throw all
you're doing is showing off yeah and he
doesn't want to do it I I completely
don't get it yeah I mean I guess I would
say this first of all that's a canned
statement oh he's he's so competitive he
might just get hey forget it guys I'm
gonna throw no that's not gonna happen
that's a canned statement from the agent
Ian Rapoport to make it sound like he's
you know this crazy competitor I'm sure
he is a crazy competitor you know am I
disappointed that he's not gonna throw
out the combine certainly yeah
definitely I want to see him out there I
want to see him next to the Dru locks in
the Dwayne Haskins and what it looks
like when they all throw out routes
together right you could compare and oh
this guy gets it out of his hands
quicker but at the same time I'm not
gonna be mad at him because again these
is the way it's set up and if he doesn't
feel like he's sitting hitting on all
cylinders and we talked about it all the
time he is a guy that I think when
people watch the film they're gonna go
he's a top 15 pick he's a top 20 pick so
you know he could literally sit back
there and I think just go look at my
film look at all the throws I make I can
do it all but I am disappointed just as
a sports fan and as a quarterback fan
who is it that made the point this week
that maybe one of the reasons that Colin
Murray doesn't want to throw is he
doesn't want to stand next I was that
was you yes yeah damn did you forget you
mean I was me yeah we were together for
nine hours yesterday I was you were
somebody else it was me yes I do think
that could be part of that maybe it's a
night thing yeah like he doesn't want to
look like you know inadequate next to it
there's Dwayne Haskins and drew Locke
that between skins into a Tonga by llola
at the Heisman ceremony we've shown the
picture optic it's like a little kid
right in the middle of two grown men and
so you know you're out there and that
the tight you know underwear and right
walking around and yeah it's gonna be
obvious and he's gonna be smaller than
the receivers - that's things gonna be
smaller than anybody that's around yeah
people also say he is as oh my god
that's amazing
people who have watched him say though
he's also the best pure thrower so
seconds after you say my goodness he's
short you would be saying if this is all
true he throws it better than everybody
else does - yes no I know you're right
there's definitely that all 32 teams are
gonna go to his pro day at Oklahoma
regardless I think that and you know I I
know you and I talked about this like
leading up with a Super Ball even this
week look maybe he wasn't quite working
out a whole lot after the bowl game
wasn't sure what he was gonna do
baseball or football so he feels like he
just needs another week or two under his
belt of throwing ball and getting back
into you know quarterback mode and he
needs to lose some of the weight that
he's gained so he weighs 206 this week
he's got to lose about 10 pound right he
can move 40 hours on Friday have a great
day
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports